4 good news for the planet.
And they are really nice!
1st good news,
since the beginning of the month,
the former Leclerc declares
stop paper advertising,
which represents 50,000t less paper per year.
2nd good news,
the creation of a new global fund
for biodiversity
has been ratified
by the international community in Vancouver.
The background
aims to accelerate the protection of 30% of the planet
of the two-thousand-thirty site.
3rd positive news,
in New Zealand,
the takae bird makes its return to the wild
when he was thought to be off.
4th good news,
the atomic equator
the reduction of1.000.000.000 dollars in its debt
against the Daloué commitment
quatre-cent-cinquante $1,000,000
to the conservation of the Galapagos Islands.